[Music]
The Big Bang Theory starting up again
how's it going you obviously you guys
lead a charmed life people love the show
anything new going on um it's been going
great so far on the first episode of the
season I had a little incident oh this
is your character had it or you actually
had an incident um maybe I had it as my
character it was we were shooting a
scene and I'm supposed to be I'm in a
hotel room bed and in my own personal
life whenever I get under covers I'm
always really cold so I just tend to
pull the covers up really high and just
leave my head out and then I kind of
like warm up my hand like I'm a Boy
Scout starting a fire with sticks or
something yeah so I'm under the covers
and it's really cold unsaid cuz they
keep it cold and I'm under there we're
shooting the scene and out of habit I'm
doing this under the covers and we shot
the whole scene and then after there's a
studio audience a studio audience and
after the scene was over our director
and producers came over to me and they
were like we need to see your hands in
the next take it looked like you were
having way too much fun
under the covers really yeah and then
after the show I we were we take our
vows and I was talking to some people in
the audience and this little boy said to
music did you shoot that scene again
with your hands out cuz it looked weird
cuz my dad said it looked real weird
oh my dad said he liked it my dad's
under arrest
Wow yeah yeah cuz you can't you can't
know you called your mom I call my mom
to tell her and which she asked me on
the first episode when I told her and
she was mortified
people understand that you weren't
really doing that that's disgusting
people have been fired from that people
have lost the Koreans but doing that in
the movie theaters she's so she's so
upset about he's also acting like it's
the 1940s you know yeah that's that's
charming yeah so now every week I just
keep on saying
Oh something else happen I wear so your
mom's Woody Allen my mom